carvana is the new way to buy a car and
we are known for our car vending machine
structures
we've been providing as soon as next day
delivery to the las vegas market for a
few years now
and the opportunity to bring our
signature car vetting machine to the
area was exciting
uh we debuted the world's first coin
operated fully automated card vending
machine
in nashville in 2015 and we're excited
to bring the new way to buy car to as
many people as possible so
with this las vegas location it adds
something really fun to the las vegas
skyline so our car running machines are
a great brand builder they bring a lot
of attention and eyes to our brand
but mostly it's a representation of how
where the new way to buy a car
it's very different from the traditional
experience it puts the customer in
charge of the transaction it allows them
to
do their next purchase when where and
how they would like it when you walk in
the door you've you've selected a day
and time convenient for you to do that
you'll be greeted by one of our customer
advocates
and they will hand you an oversized
commemorative carvana coin special to
our car vetting machines
uh you will approach the slot machine
you'll insert the coin in you'll pull
the lever
and that will bring the car vending
machine to life you'll get to see your
car
descend from the all glass tower and
then you when it's
on the ground floor you can go take a
look at it you can take it for a quick
spin if you want but
that's when your seven day return policy
begins so you really do have a week to
to live with the car and make sure it's
the one for you um walk you through some
paperwork and
then you can be on your way so really it
can be done in a matter of minutes uh
compared to hours you might spend at a
traditional dealership